delphine wespiser était avec nous ce
soir delphine votre ami votre fiancée
roger les années passent et nuit pour la
saint valentin dans un château
complètement chose à mon avis cette
caméra cachée elle va faire partie du
top 3 joue de vie des plus grands draps
sera qu'un chroniqueur et vécu c'est un
véritable film on est d'accord défini en
fait vous avez super bien choisi le
sujet et parce que je suis très sensible
à ça et donc je suis tombé dans le piège
actuellement il est à 100 ce piège
regardez là c'est de la plage vous dites
là vous allez regarder une fin film
j'avais regardé une fiction ça il ya les
moyens de ouf me regarde
[Musique]
bonsoir madame bonsoir monsieur moussa
alors registre réservation oui qu'il
irait là 17 à 17 h arbaud louise
archambault louise oui vous allez voir
les magnifiques vous êtes déjà vu au
château ici nous unit non mais vous
connaissez pas l'histoire du château
alors remarqué de montespan s'est
installé ici à peu près de 200 ans avec
toute sa famille est là marchisio louise
sa femme entretenait une relation avec
le palefrenier accord les deux amants se
sont débarrassés du marquis ne l'a
jamais revu tant qu'il n'est pas dans
notre art moi je pense pas
ne vous inquiétez pas eh bien monsieur
s'il vous plaît encore bagages mission
merci
veuillez me suivre s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
je souhaite un très très bon séjour
merci merci beaucoup je dirai pas ce qui
[Musique]
est énorme
hier c'est comme dans les châteaux non
ça [ __ ]
roger quoi tu fermes ce que je ne me
sens pas bien je ne crois pas je suis
pas de souci je ne le sens pas bien je
te dis je sois rejet chérif j'ai rien
fait par contre là il ya un truc bizarre
franchement qua non et f
regarde là me fait peur non mais regarde
la meuf [ __ ] les yeux de la meuf et ta
bouche là on garde le tableau on dirait
que c'est toi sémalens flippant je te
jure fait la raison et spectacles
franchement on dirait toi enfin toi il
ya 200 ans quoi dégager son mari benj
pas déjà là cocufié ce que j'aimerais
bien par contre c'est ouvrir cette
fenêtre
si le truc l'un d'eux ça marche je veux
pas te mettre même nettoie à côté du
truc sur une photo à rades maintenant
mais écoute je je te dis je me sens pas
à l'aise je ne sens pas la douche moi ça
marche au je suis pas à l'aise dans ce
club ben pourquoi c'est quoi ce cap où
les bouges la presse que ce soit des
trucs ça me dérange urgent et choula au
niveau du perthus sérieuse n'est pas
enchanté 1 1 mais c'est pas que j'ai pas
enchanté c'est que je me sens pas à
l'aise
ça fait un peu peur surtout sa position
ne trouve pas mâche pas moi j'aime bien
qu'est ce qu'il ya mais je jure [ __ ]
et di resta quoi il s'agit c'est bon
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans la salle de bain
ne payez rien du blanche s'arrête mais
pour moi
[Musique]
et si ça te fait flipper je demande une
autre chambre
voilà je voulais te faire plaisir c'est
pas cool c'est une question tu que je te
dise vraiment vas-y jean-michel et
maxime naud j'ai un peu discuté à que je
dis [ __ ] je voudrais faire une
surprise nana na na na na ils m'ont dit
franchement c'est un endroit deux ça
fait la famille adams et injures
peut-être qu'ils m'ont fait une petite
vanne maxime et et jean-michel je pense
ouais ben je pense ouais pareil cas et
je vais leur envoyer une facture les
deux bonsoir c'est la réception votre
table après y'a quoi au menu votre table
et prête jeudi à quoi au menu raccrocher
mais je te jure ya les autres et cela
j'ai l'impression de me voir à
l'extérieur
j'ai l'impression que la lumière elle
est bizarre j'ai l'impression que je
suis dans un jeu on vient on à manger se
sentira mieux après merci beaucoup c'est
vrai ça c'est sûr saint valentin je te
mets additionnant prise de risque
non ça c'est sûr
je
[Musique]
ça va comprendre
jamais
[Musique]
roger ça
je maintiens quoi jean paul ricard est
qu'il ya cinq ans je viens de passer et
elle regardait pas par les clients et
est le père d'une amie qui sont six pas
lachmann couvre garder mais je savais
qu'elle reviendra je savais que
j'ai l'impression de vous révèle dans sa
réponse logique
j'emporte que tu mènes posséder de quoi
je faisais un monstre j'ai une plage de
gier et la protéger ça fait depuis le
premier jour que je t'ai vu que je suis
là pour te protéger alors one en les
serrant version s'enrichit l'installeur
persie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
papa et moi
et
[Musique]
la rosée qui est derrière de là vous
vous êtes installé vous a fait une belle
surprise et vous commencez à avoir une
petite race sera un match que vous
auriez été pareil verbaux je veux tous
vous amener la balle et je termine ma
soupe et ouais c'est d'abord ce qui se
passe après parce que là ça va monter en
puissance
regardez la deuxième partie waouh de
cette histoire c'est parti il souhaite
un très très bon séjour du palais il a
tous les coups j'ai l'impression que je
sors des trucs ça me regarde la meuf ce
jury est une fée au crès ça va très bien
[Musique]
cherry a pas plu et humour pour le
plaisir quatre et demi bairi comme des
blaireaux
je suis au bord de la tachycardie
sérieux voilà c'était pour l'amour mais
bon mais pour l'amour [ __ ] on peut
faire l'amour à mieux serait qu'à la
mairie mais il est loin le temps où nous
manquiez rien à expliquer sans voir pire
ne rien expliquer ce papa de massage pas
d'âme pas de soirée par mois déjà merci
beaucoup
bon séjour à voir
j'aime pas de couverts je cherchais des
couleurs pour moi elle est ouverte la
porte
oui alors date il va se retrouver tout
seul dans la chambre
oh là là et là un cauchemar va démarrer
on repart je cherche des couleurs pour
moi elle est ouverte la porte
[Musique]
jmahri
non
oh oh
puis sahel moi oh [ __ ] chéri ouvrent
eux j'ai commencé à pleurer [ __ ] je
suis enfermé merde
/
[Musique]
attends mouche pas
j'étais là
raccord bouge pas je claque
oui tu restes de vols à bas coûts vrai
moi cette borne et je la touche pas je
m'enfonce éléphants
je veux dire
j'ai l'air
[Musique]
m
c'est bon
les attend vous voyez pas votre voiture
ou en train de brûler sur le parc
commence à ma voix duel en train de
pulls et chérie chéri organes ce qui se
passait
t les pompiers [ __ ] mais les pompiers
se passe ici
[Musique]
cherry volant
qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Musique]
j'arrive pas bizarre qu'est ce qui se
passe et à la voix d'eric là
sow revient ici bien son jeu 2d avait
pas
à
j'arrive pas ouvrir
hu
cherchez moisi l'accord
[Applaudissements]
t'auras pas dû
[Musique]
c'est moi elle a quoi ma voiture je
n'excuse pas nos âmes
mais la courbe aventurons gamelle
ce comprend rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir au sénat je savais que tu
viendras la maison tu as fait des
misères n'ai pas peur
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je comprends ce que tu fais là voilà la
vraie peur en fait c'est un truc de fou
moi c'est bon
[Applaudissements]